[Musica]
parliamo di digitare di democrazia
digitale e allora proviamo a farci una
domanda partiamo da delle domande è la
prima è la rete è democratica paesi la
risposta è sì assolutamente la rete è
qualcosa che ha aperto alla
comunicazione di tutti è il luogo dove
tutti possono esprimersi la libertà di
pensiero
le tecnologie digitali sono democratiche
si perché vengono sviluppate con i loro
servizi e applicazioni per il bene
comune per il bene di tutti per
migliorare la vita di tutti
proviamo a invertire i termini e
proviamo a farci un'altra domanda ma c'è
democrazia sulla rete la risposta non è
così scontata c'è qualcosa che cambia
e allora per fare questo dobbiamo
analizzare innanzitutto i termini la
democrazia quando c'è una democrazia una
democrazia cioè quando una comunità si
riunisce per condividere un progetto
comune un progetto un progetto di vita
quando c'è un desiderio di convivenza è
fondamentale un rispetto verso le
singole identità a un progetto comune e
quindi si dà delle regole si dà delle
regole con alcuni diritti e doveri ben
determinati perché vuole stare insieme
c'è una grande volontà e la rete nella
rete internet internet non è una
comunità singola in realtà internet è
una serie di comuni di comunità
verticali verticali perché perché sono
di settore e noi tutti noi cittadini
decidiamo di partecipare a quelle
singole comunità perché abbiamo
determinati interessi ci sono comunità
economiche ci sono comunità per fare
viaggi ci sono comunità per la cultura
per per esprimere noi stessi ma questa è
la rete ospita una serie di comunità e
il il cittadino digitale
chi è chi è l'internauta bell internauta
è un
è un curioso è uno che dice tutto al
contrario di tutto che vuole scrivere
come vuole esprimersi che partecipa
sulla rete ma è in un deserto senza
regole è un pioniere si inventa se
stesso e come lo fa spesso lo farà
attraverso una una propria identità beh
non sempre è quasi sempre un identità
nascosta è un'identità inventata e
anonimizzata non c'è un'unica identità
non si confronta con il prossimo non si
riconosce lui stesso detto nella
comunità e allora io ho fatto un po di
analisi cercato di capire ma c'è una
genesi c'è un motivo
il perché di tutto questo e allora il
peccato originale se così lo possiamo
chiamare sta proprio nella sua genesi
tutti noi individui abbiamo deciso di
partecipare a una comunità una rete
facendo cosa è un contratto in contratto
io ho scritto verbale un accordo tacito
tra noi e le grandi piattaforme
informatiche e qui siamo già a fine
degli anni 90 quindi è passato del tempo
noi abbiamo fatto un accordo un accordo
tacito che prevedeva di fronte alla
gratuita dei propri dei servizi
concedere le nostre personalità i nostri
dati salvo poi capire negli ultimi anni
e la norma lo sa
la norma i garanti europei lo hanno
riconosciuto che il dato personale anche
un dato economico siamo andati molto
avanti siamo andati oltre alcuni tempi
allora proviamo a fare un passo indietro
il problema a pensare come vorremmo
disegnarci questo nostro futuro
beh quello che serve un patto nuovo
digitale un patto nuovo digitale non lo
si fa come tanti singoli individui ma
servono governi servono serve la società
civile
servono le aziende ovviamente le aziende
produttrici della tecnologia e delle
grandi piattaforme ma serve un nuovo
accordo per far cosa
per creare proprio quella comunità per
cercare di trovare un luogo dove
identificarsi dove tutte le singole
persone possano sentirsi rappresentate
ma deve essere il luogo fondamentalmente
dove non c'è discriminazione nei persone
per religione né per colore è questo il
mondo che noi vogliamo se noi come se io
che devo condividere una mia con un con
il mio prossimo alcuni valori a valori
che non sempre sono scritti e molto più
spesso sono tramandati sono valori che
io mi sono ritrovato e ho ereditato di
fatto ma io vorrei vivere in quel mondo
lì un mondo dove non c'è discriminazione
un mondo dove c'è una forte inclusione
perché dove c'è inclusione c'è
convivenza dove c'è convivenza c'è
voglia di provare un progetto comune di
vita non solo ma anche partecipare la
possibilità di tutti di partecipare ai
processi e processi democratici ci sono
tante forme nel negli ultimi anni
particolarmente anche in italia
noi abbiamo visto delle forme di
democrazia così chiamata e democracy
democrazia diretta
sono quasi tutte fallimentari in un modo
o nell'altro sono fallimentari perché
arrivano un limite che quando cresce c'è
un interesse di fondo o di qualcuno o di
un'organizzazione che vuole
rappresentarla ma allora la libertà di
quella libertà per cui la rete è
democratica è fatta di partecipazione è
fatta di singole voci
ora tutto questo però non è un qualcosa
che ci regalano nessuno ce lo regala in
realtà con qualcosa che ce lo dobbiamo
guadagnare lo dobbiamo proteggere se
vogliamo questo c'è un impegno quando si
parla di una democrazia cosa è una
democrazia di fatto non è un punto di
arrivo non è un raggiungimento non è
oggi vivo dentro la democrazia una
democrazia come un fuoco va alimentato
va a seguito quel calore va seguito se
vogliamo avere altre persone intorno al
nostro focolare questo va alimentato e
lo stesso è quello che noi dobbiamo fare
se vogliamo la democrazia nel mondo del
digitale vedete oggi sempre più gli
attacchi informatici mettono in dubbio o
comunque in in creano dei problemi
enormi per per la democrazia
e quando io parlo di un attacco
informatico è un attacco che riguarda i
cittadini
soprattutto durante la pandemia sono
cresciuti quelli che si chiamano in
national in action state attack che sono
sono governi che attaccano a tre governi
per motivi geopolitici per vari motivi
ma quando un governo attacca un altro
governo attacca i cittadini perché si
attaccano i servizi essenziali ai
cittadini e negli ultimi anni abbiamo
avuto e hanno nomi e cognomi di attacchi
che hanno colpito il sistema giudiziario
il sistema sanitario il sistema quello
che riguarda tutti noi cittadini giorno
per giorno
se diamo un valore agli attacchi
informatici oggi parliamo di 5.000
miliardi di euro annui di costi generati
dagli attacchi allora con c'è qualcosa
che dobbiamo fare dobbiamo difendere i
processi democratici si dobbiamo
difendere tutti quei momenti in cui il
cittadino ha una voce di un processo
democratico che sono sicuramente le
campagne elettorali che sono sicuramente
il momento del voto
oggi questi sono i momenti in cui per
motivi di nuovo geopolitici sono quelli
molto più a rischio
e qui c'è un impegno che dobbiamo avere
tutte ma prima di tutto doveva avere una
coscienza
ma c'è un altro aspetto importante se
vogliamo combattere le azioni le
attività che fanno governi in ambito
digitale contro altri governi
dobbiamo darci delle norme
internazionali delle regole
internazionali e sono regole che poi
dobbiamo seguire tutti ma non le
seguiamo e le dobbiamo seguire perché
perché riguardano la vita di nuovo di
tutti noi cittadini perché hanno un
effetto sulla vita di tutti di tutti noi
e allora di che cosa parliamo parliamo
che un governo se usa la tecnologia e
del per quanto sofisticata possa essere
lo fa soltanto per motivi difensivi non
offensivi serve un nuovo patto fra
governi perché ci sia un impegno
affinché la tecnologia venga utilizzata
non per scopi offensivi ma solo
difensivi ma serve anche delle norme per
la non proliferazione delle armi
cibernetiche
allora proviamo a pensare un paragone un
paragone nel mondo del nucleare
quando uno pensa al nucleare pensa alla
non proliferazione end e pensa anche
all'agenzia del nucleare un'entità
sovranazionale che ci possa aiutare a
garantire che ci sia veramente un uso
consapevole e non indiscriminato delle
tecnologie informatiche tra stati
pestati contro stati e in ultimo è
difendere la pace del mondo digitale ed
i diritti umani allora come si fa questo
beh questo è un lavoro immenso che
prevede però alla base il valore più
importante che spesso noi ci
dimentichiamo cioè l'attivismo noi
dobbiamo passare a essere parte attiva
di questo fenomeno di questo processo
riportare l'uomo al centro al centro
dello sviluppo tecnologico perché
riguarda tutti noi e che cosa che
dobbiamo fare è la prima cosa più
importante ed è a livello globale perché
internet la rete la democrazia digitale
è globale è quella di darci delle regole
e una serie di diritti e doveri e avere
anche un sistema giurisprudenziale che
ci possa garantire che queste regole
vengano effettivamente esercitate e oggi
quando si parla di informatica forense è
molto difficile
un po perché avevamo dell'identità
abbiamo delle identità non definite e
quindi è molto difficile l'attività
scientifica e investigativa a dall'altra
perché non esistono ancora delle regole
internazionali di scambi di informazioni
e in ultimo dobbiamo promuovere la
convivenza nel mondo del digitale nel
rispetto delle singole identità e questo
è fondamentale
vedete le parole fanno tanto tanto male
ma le parole nel mondo del digitale sono
delle tracce indelebili
noi pensiamo sempre alla fake news alla
diffamazione ma una parola nel mondo del
digitale lascia una traccia indelebile
che sta a vita
e questa non va solo combattuta ma va
anche conosciuto quali sono le identità
dei singoli persone del pianeta
altrimenti non parleremo mai di
convivenza nel mondo del digitale come
nel mondo reale
vi lascio con una con una frase che è
sicuramente più bravo di me in modo così
diretto a riassumere un concetto che è
fondamentale da parte di un informatico
quanto li nell'informatica la
multidisciplinarietà e fondamentale
informatici che parlano di filosofia
diritti dell'uomo eccetera beh il alan
kay è uno dei padri della programmazione
è il un informatico statunitense vivente
il quale disse che per dice è tuttora
per prevedere il futuro
l'unico modo inventarlo e questo che
cosa significa significa che dobbiamo
giocare un ruolo attivo nella società
dobbiamo impegnarci per far sì che non
viviamo e non dobbiamo vivere dentro una
tecnocrazia e quindi quando la
tecnologia di fatto domina e decide gran
parte della vita di noi cittadini sul
digitale ma dobbiamo giocare un ruolo
attivo e disegnare il nostro futuro per
una democrazia digitale grazie